[Music]
one hundred years ago
this week russia's imperial family the
romanovs
were murdered by the bolsheviks the
country's marxist revolutionaries
today russia has a leader who many
believe is positioning himself
as a new kind of tsar
[Music]
russia's president has adopted some of
the trappings of an imperial ruler
but he also admires the country's soviet
past
so this anniversary is a tricky moment
for the president
[Music]
july 1918 a civil war
raged across russia's vast lands between
bolshevik forces
led by lenin and the white army loyal to
tsar nicholas ii
[Music]
the bolsheviks had seized power eight
months previously
established a socialist workers republic
and soon after had imprisoned nicholas
and his family
in the city of yekerenberg
then on the night of july 16th
the bolsheviks did the unthinkable
the bolsheviks decided to shoot emperor
nicholas ii
with his wife and all his family in the
basement
of the so-called apative house in the
city
there were many ballots it was a very
violent and horrifying shooting
nicholas his wife alexandra their five
children
and servants were dumped in unmarked
graves
the news would send shockwaves around
the world
today russia is ruled by a modern day
autocrat
vladimir putin putin believes in
statehood
but it can be embodied only in the
person of the leader
and the monarch that's the symbol the
power and the embodiment of the state
real power rests with mr putin while the
duma
russia's parliament like nicholas's
parliament in the early 1900s
wields little real authority
[Music]
and like russia's tsars mr putin has
tried to maintain his grip on power
through political repression at home and
military conflict abroad
in both ukraine and syria
[Applause]
the romanovsas were closely supported by
the russian orthodox church
mr putin has worked to
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
but the centenary of the romanov murders
poses a challenge for mr putin
the dilemma facing vladimir putin
is to navigate between
strongly condemning the act of murder
of the last emperor and his family and
on the other side
not condemning the regime and the
political system
which was established after the
revolution
by the people who actually killed the
zone
russia's president has tried to sidestep
the barbarity of the romanov murders
to present a revisionist version of
modern russian history
putin is banned on restoring the great
country has the vision of the great
russia
you can rename the state
and the position of authority but it is
still
for him the same centralized state
with the all-powerful autocrat
[Music]
mr putin isn't the first president to
grapple with the legacy of the romanovs
in 1998 the remains of tsar nicholas and
his family were identified
[Music]
then president boris yeltsin used the
tsar's reburial
to acknowledge that the murders were a
crime
and to break away from russia's soviet
past
[Music]
democratic
in mr putin the church's hierarchy has
found an
ally who celebrates russia's imperial
past
while the 65 year old president has used
the church's support
to bolster his image as russia's
anointed savior
mr putin remains popular in part because
he has muzzled any real political
opposition
like the tsars he resists calls for
democratic reform
putin believes that russian people want
strong leader
and don't want the mess of the
democratic politics
the russian president's grip on power
remains strong
but as russian history has shown the
country's systems of government
can rise and fall in unpredictable ways
you